[Applause]
see ma'am I love your dress I love our
green Ensemble we I know I was like you
were your green it is weird though it
has like random yellow that you think is
an accident it's not um how are you this
holiday season you love Christmas good I
do yeah I I love the holiday so much me
too it makes me so happy do you all have
like you have a big family right I do
have a huge family yeah do you all have
any tradition we have a lot of
traditions we wear matching onesies I
get onesies for my entire family we
usually start watching the har poters
and we just watch every single one every
that's me and my kid you just explained
my house with me and my kids really yes
oh my gosh I thought I was crazy no I
literally put them like I I think when
they were younger I was like this might
be too soon for Lord Voldemort because
it's a little scary you know the
Dementors all of it and then nope they
didn't care and yeah we watch it every
yeah I love a onesie thing will everyone
in your family get in it oh yeah I force
them all I love it yeah I I even have it
for our dogs of course you can't they
family you can't forget them those are
four-legged family members I this is my
favorite thing I've heard about you
you're so talented and so beautiful and
gifted but I love this story I heard
that the house that you grew up in which
was like many generations of your family
y'all ended up losing that house and
then you bought it back yes so it was my
great grandma's
house I love it thank
you how did y lose it what happened well
no so it was my my grandma my great
grandma had this beautiful house um it's
like a two-bedroom cute house at they
lived in my grandma was born in my mom
was born in it and then as the kids got
older they built on the property another
home and when my great grandpa passed
away and my great grandmother got old
they just couldn't afford to keep it
anymore yeah they upkeep it and yeah
it's a lot and last year I called up the
owners and I said I want to buy my great
grandma's house back that's
amazing I think that's so cool man and
it's really cool too um my my grandy
still lives in the house next door so
I'm neighbors with MC Grandy now you're
like a Hallmark movie like you're like a
do you get into those at Christmas time
I do you do yeah the lessons though that
you got from your parents I heard that
you had just such a great upbringing
like what's one that you kind of carry
with you uh well my mom was very hard on
me which I thank her very much my mom
was hard on me too look I got to work
EIC like no other ex yeah my mom was
hard on me too yeah um but she always
wanted me to be able to do everything
myself and be independent and not rely
on anybody else and if we were driving
like when I was learning how to drive a
car she only let me drive a manual until
I got my license and uh she made me
learn how to change my tire even if my
my tire didn't need to get changed yeah
um yeah just that comes in handy it does
when you're on the side of the road and
your brother bought new shoes and he
won't get out in the rain until you do
it
[Laughter]
yourself I was like are you serious
right now and I've got the manual I'm
like out they're trying to it's pouring
down the one day it rains in La a year
anyway it was really funny but we can
change tires can you change oil I can do
that too I'm so handy I love us I love
us we would survive the apocalypse I
really would yes we have something else
in comment I love theme parks and you
worked at Universal did you not I worked
at Six Flags Over Texas whenever I was a
teenager yeah no I worked Six Flags me
too no I was a huge theme park person my
family and all of our friends would go
to Universal all the time to the point
that I've memorize the Universal Studios
tour and oh like the tram yes oh my God
I love that's my favorite thing ever I
can go there and just recite everything
mouth every word they say see and
parents like the tram because you sit
down exactly for a little bit yeah yeah
just for a little bit but it's fun it's
Interac but yeah I I mean like every
high school kid needed a a job and I was
taken anything that I could get yeah I
loved it I actually worked at sixs and I
I loved working in a theme par it's just
like a happy place yeah it is yeah and
there are worse jobs I couldn't do a
cubicle I'd go mad that'd be hard yeah
people would hate me in that environment
yeah do you remember the speech from the
tram I'm not reciting
that she said absolutely not yes I do
but I bow out no explain the new movie
I'm actually very excited about this I
haven't seen it yet so anyone but you
tell everybody so it comes to theaters
December 22nd it's a enemies to lovers
romcom love it's so I love Glen pal too
I I'm such a fan of both of you and I
was very excited to know you doing a
film and I love a romcom yeah no it was
just it was so magical we filmed it in
Sydney Australia which is one of the
most beautiful places I've fall in love
with it and it's based off of
Shakespeare's much to do about nothing
and it's a modern take on it and you cry
you laugh it's a really good time oh my
God I thank you cuz I miss movies like
this people don't make them enough
anymore no they used to be like so like
prevalent like all the time but now they
don't make it yeah we want we want a
romcom Renaissance to the theat we want
them to have fun and enjoy themselves
there's big set pieces like we're making
the romcom big again I love that I love
how did you how did you like Australia
you love love I love Australia I'm
actually filming another movie in
Australia right now too oh that's
awesome rute for this interview oh you
know just a couple 20 hours oh my God
that's horrible yeah not enough wine in
the world to help me in that scenario
yeah the jet lag is horrible but I love
it once you get there man it's so
beautiful it's amazing and also the
Aussies are the
people ever um I also hear you did
something else fun cuz I saw this video
um you did a it's like a natural water
slide in where is this cuz I've been to
Australia many times yeah this is
actually so Joe who he's in anyone but
you with us um when I was there like a
couple weeks ago he was showing me
queensl cuz that's where I'm filming the
new one and he took me to this waterfall
that's just a natural water slide wow
yeah so no bumps that really hurt like
as you were no no it's actually I was
worried myself yeah you never know
what's going to hit someone smooth this
out probably not yeah yeah no someone
else took it for me natural water slide
though I've never done that very Goonies
that's too old for you but you should
see Goonies it's a great film I'll make
sure to check it out okay see never
heard of it I thought so um I am 41 uh
so you I hear that you this is really
cool but you're really cool and hot like
you work on cars on sets which I heard
that's so cool so you work on old and I
have AFF for an old one oh no way now I
had it restored by someone who knew what
they were doing cuz I'm not that person
but I had it restored like to its
classic like thing the only thing was
the engine I had a Coy Coyote 5.0 pit in
because I can't I don't want to work on
an engine girl but you actually work on
them and like restore them yeah so my
best friend's dad who she's actually
here in the audience Jade hi
[Applause]
Jade um her dad builds and restores
classic Porsches and and I bought this
Ford Bronco and I called him up and he's
been like a second dad to me my whole
life and I was like hey I bought this
old car I want to fix it up but I kind
of want to learn how to do it myself so
Co and so he let me bring it into the
shop and he just walked me through every
step and we changed the transmissions
and the brakes and the interior and it
was it's like incredible how you keep
getting hotter as this conversation goes
on like it's just so cool like I'm like
what I just see you like with the car
and you're just thinking you look awful
but it's like a romcom and you look
beautiful and like it's so cool I love
that you restore cars did you drive in
Australia at all were you brave enough
oh of course okay they actually tested
every single person on the cast if they
could drive a manual but on the opposite
side of the road look what your mother
prepared you for oh and guess what I'm
the only one who could
oh this is a personal shout out to your
mama yes that is so cool yes still Glenn
couldn't do it either cuz I would have
rubbed that he needed well he needed a
couple more lessons ah I love it I love
it anyone but you in theater starting
December 22nd
[Music]
[Applause]
y thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going home
[Music]